Good morning John; it's Thursday, January
25th. Yesterday, you said it was Thursday;
today I'm saying it's Thursday. One of us
is wrong. As you may have noticed in my January
23rd video, I'm currently in Mom and Dad's
little cabin on the side of their house. Katherine
and I have begun our yearly Tour of the Entire
Southeastern United States!
We're starting out in Asheville, North Carolina,
which is right here. Then we're going to jaunt
over to Athens, Georgia to see some friends,
and then jaunt back from Georgia to Asheville,
and then we're going to jaunt from Asheville
to Orlando, that jaunt being in an airplane
- by all accounts this is a lot of jaunting
- and then we're gonna jaunt in a car from
Orlando to Tampa St. Petersburg to see some
friends, and then from Tampa St. Petersburg
we're going to jump to Englewood, Florida
which is pretty far down on the Gulf Coast.
Two of the three weeks I'll be on this trip
I'll be without high speed internet. Not okay.
You said that you believed that Mom and Dad's
house was the last residence in the United
States of America with dial-up internet. You
were wrong. There's an entire town on the
Gulf Coast of Florida without broadband internet.
And I'm about to go there.
I'm very concerned for what this means for
the Brotherhood 2.0 project. I'm also very
concerned because a lot of people have been
coming up with a lot of very good punishments.
These aren't the kind of punishments that
are just difficult to do, they're the kind
of punishments that are extremely embarrassing
to have on video blog, and that's the kind
of punishments that we're going to want to
be doing!
So I've decided something. As the Brotherhood
2.0 brother who may be very likely be making
his first foray into punishment territory,
I would like to suggest that the brother not
being punished decide which punishment to
give the brother being punished. That way,
I just don't take the punishment I'd most
want to do, but you'd give me the punishment
you'd most want our viewers to see me doing.
You were right about another thing about Asheville,
North Carolina. I'm surrounded by memories
of my childhood.
Do you remember when Phil Wood made us these
little critter cages so we could catch grasshoppers
and store them inside? So they can be punished
for the crimes of their incessant chirping!
They never really worked very well.
This reminds me of my childhood because it
is a little dog that I made to resemble our
little dog, Red, and the doghouse that we
never had. He doesn't actually fit inside
the doghouse.
Oddly enough, one of the things that remind
me most of my childhood in this place is the
food. Mom made Shepard's Pie last night! And
also, something I haven't seen since I left
home... a Kraft American cheese individually
wrapped single. It, ah, it smells like nothi-
I mean, it doesn't, it's not cheese; it doesn't
look or smell like cheese, it doesn't...(laughs)
cheese doesn't wobble like this, holy crap!
There's really three ways I'd eat one of these-
on a white bread sandwich with turkey, all
by itself on a tortilla, microwaved, or folded
in quarters - bwaaa (laughs) - and then eat
it.
Mmm, delicious cheese. Kinda.
I enjoyed your survey, and hopefully I'll
see more of it tomorrow.